ED GLAESER: We are at the Waterworks Museum in Chestnut Hill,
here in Boston, which is an amazing place, filled with the machines that
made Boston sanitary in the 1800s.
DAVID CUTLER: What you're looking at here is probably
the greatest innovation affecting health in the US
and around the world in three centuries.
GLAESER: Clean water?
More than penicillin?
More than any form of heart surgery?
CUTLER: If you look in the data, there's
a golden age of mortality reductions in the late 19th century,
early in the 20th century, where mortality fell more rapidly
than at any period in American history.
Most of what was killing people was infectious disease.
GLAESER: And more so in cities than in rural areas.
CUTLER: Much more so in cities.
Infectious disease spreads from person to person.
So the denser is the population, the more it spreads.
GLAESER: The easier it is to spread.
CUTLER: The leading cause of death at the
time was tuberculosis, which is primarily airborne.
But the second leading cause of death or causes were really waterborne disease:
cholera, typhoid fever, a whole host of bacteria that live in the water
and would circulate through from human waste
into groundwater or into streams and rivers.
And that would then be used for drinking.
GLAESER: And then people would die.
CUTLER: People would die.
And so throughout the 19th and the 20th centuries,
you had immense outbreaks of infectious diseases.
In city after city, roughly every decade or so,
you'd see this big outbreak of disease.
GLAESER: Now this waterworks mania
that made our cities-- far from infecting our cities,
it disinfected our cities, begins with a mistake, right?
It begins with a disease that is not in fact waterborne,
but that led to a watering commission in Philadelphia on the 1790s.
CUTLER: Yellow fever, which we now think
of as a tropical disease in low income countries,
where it still is, yellow fever was prominent in areas of the US
that got very hot and had lots of mosquitoes.
But the good thing that comes from it is that Philadelphia
decides to build a waterworks.
So, they hire Benjamin Latrobe, he of British nationality
who goes on to build the capital in the US.
And Philadelphia sets up the first clean water system, giving proof
to one of the things that you need.
You need a kind of engineering class that can go ahead and do it,
so an engineering class that can bring this mammoth construction
to bear to improve the people's health.
This is the great wave of engineering, one of the great waves of engineering.
So this is sanitation engineers and environmental engineers and people
who learn how to transport water, 20 miles in the case of Boston,
40 miles in the case of New York, get clean water to cities.
Interestingly, they're all public employees.
So they all get hired by the public sector.
They get taken out of the political process, which
fights for decades and decades over how we're going to get water,
where we're going to get water.
And they bring sort of a professional class.
They start their own journals, "The Journal of the American Water Works
Association" and "The Water Works Journal," and so on.
And they're communicating with each other.
And they're basically cleaning up America's cities.
GLAESER: And are they typically independent agencies,
independent entities?
CUTLER: Often they're independent agencies.
Typically they would get some operational money
from supplying the water.
So, often on an ongoing basis, they would do that.
But the actual construction of the waterworks is very, very involved.
To give you a sense, in 1915, the typical American city
has more invested in their water facilities, their cleaning
and pumping facilities, than an entire year's worth of city revenue.
So actually getting the money to do this is a big deal.
You have to understand you want it.
The political process has to figure out where the water is
and how are they going to get it.
GLAESER: Part of the sanitation problem is bringing the water in,
but the other point is getting the waste, getting the waste out.
So sewers happen somewhat at the same time, somewhat later.
And they have somewhat similar, but also somewhat distinct issues, right?
CUTLER: The sewers are the complementary technology.
So you need to get the clean water in, and you
need to get the dirty water away.
And you need to treat it and do all sorts of things.
And you need to make sure that you're not dumping your sewer
into some other city down the river.
So this sewer technology-- it improves as well.
You know, there are stories about the early sewers--
and again, many of these were the sort of private companies-- the early sewers
that were not big enough for the areas they were serving.
And so whenever you had a big rain storm, they would be like cesspools.
And they get back up.
GLAESER: Yeah, that still happens in Cambridge, doesn't it?
CUTLER: Around the world, it's probably fairly common.
And so the streets would become just kind of big sewers.
And so you had to have the complementary technology to sort of dig up everything
and to put the huge sewer pipes and the sewer drains everywhere
and to drain it from individual houses.
Remember, this a period of time where we're
inventing the sort of indoor toilet, indoor water closet.
So no more outhouses and outdoor waste.
So that's actually another very big technological issue.
GLAESER: And how did they pay for all of this?
How did how the finance of this work?
CUTLER: You can imagine with a series of corrupt legislators how borrowing could
get out of hand.
So, you go through waves where cities would build up debt
and then they would default on the debt and so on.
And so you have to actually develop a system to do that.
That's probably why, that's one of the reasons why the first big waterworks
are in big cities--
New York, Philadelphia, Boston, New Orleans,
all of these cities, which were big and had readier access to capital,
before you get into the smaller cities that
are going to be defaulting on debt for whom it's difficult to know how they're
going to pay back.
GLAESER: And I'm always struck that New York had the salutary
example of the Erie Canal that it occurred maybe 15
years before the Croton aqueducts, which was also debt financed.
And it worked out marvelously well.
CUTLER: When you have that people, when you have the engineering talent,
and you can do it, you can do amazing things.
And so this is an era where there are lots
of great things being done, even at a period of time
that we think of as sort of the height of corruption of local, municipal,
state, and city governments.